يعني بما انه انت كمان اشرفتي على وجه توت
عنخ امون من منهما اكثر وسامه بين توت
عنخمون ورمسيس وهل سنحسم الجدل في وجهك
كليوباترا يعني حتى الان ناس تعتبرها يعني
ايقونه في الجمال وهناك سيعتبرونها بانها
ليست جميله على الاطلاق
[موسيقى]
همم
مشروع اعاده توجه بناء وجه الملك توت عنخ
امون كان مشروع مختلف لم يكن همم يعني كان
همم الجمجمه الرقميه ولكن الوجه نفسه همم
تم تمثيله على مجسم همم
وهي همم لا استطيع اخذ من اكثر وسامع ولكن
هي عمليه عالميه
والمقاسات هي مقاسات همم الجمجمه بالفعل
ومقاسات الوجه
المصري بالفعل فبالتالي همم معنى نحصد
عليه هو نسبه يعني كبيره جدا من الصدق
كلاهما وسيمين همم كلامه ملكين عظيم
وسيمين بطريقه بطريقه